the breeze that you're feeling isn't a
storm headed your way no it's the sign
of the rumor mill is churning once again
delivering to us an interesting bit of
speculation about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe a recent report by we got
discovered claims that Marvel Studios is
looking to bring the superhero Moon
Knight to the screen and designed a
former spider-man star to portray him
fighting an unidentified source the
outlet contends a moon night will likely
get his own movie in the MCU and that it
could be played by Andrew Garfield who
embodied the web-slinging vigilante in
2012 the amazing spider-man and its
ill-fated 2014 follow up with the
amazing spider-man 2 in really excited
we got this covered alleges and another
report that Marvel wants a movie focused
on moon nights rather than a series I
would end up on Disney Plus the company
is also reportedly aiming to get a
Jewish actor to play the role of the
nocturnal hero who has Jewish heritage
with a father who's a rabbi moon Knights
alter ego is a man named Mark Specter
who suffers from dissociative identity
disorder what many people regard him as
being simply crazy he also becomes the
emissary of the Egyptian God concho
gaining supernatural powers and
stylizing himself as a caped crime
fighter
this looks like Cohn sure it's bad
enough having that moon guts fitting in
my head pulling my strings now we wanted
to have a line of toys too well the
rumor hasn't been substantiated outside
of WGT see Garfield would fit the bill
of what Marvel is reportedly looking for
the actor is known to have Polish Jewish
ancestry his family's surname is said to
have originally been garfinkel and his
paternal grandparents were part of
Jewish immigrant families while Garfield
has described himself as religiously
being more of an agnostic he does
identify as Jewish and is proud of his
Jewish heritage the idea of Garfield
joining the MCU and his post spider-man
days to become moon night is pretty
mind-boggling but truth be told this
rumor is very thin the famously
secretive Marvel Studios
hasn't said a peep about whether a movie
or series about moon nights is even a
possibility studio President Kevin Feige
has been known to keep a zipped lip on
details about future projects but he did
loosen up a great deal during 2019 San
Diego comic-con at the event Marvel held
its hotly anticipated presentation at
which the complete slate of films and TV
series that will comprise phase four of
the MCU was a
Feige even revealed that a played reboot
starring maher Sheela Ali was in the
works and confirmed the Black Panther to
Captain Marvel to guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 a Fantastic Four movie and
a film about the x-men were all under
way a marvel there wasn't a word about
moon Knights not for the far off
unannounced phase 5 and certainly not
for phase 4
now just because Feige and his fellow
Marvel executives haven't said anything
about developing a movie centered on
Moon Knights doesn't mean that it won't
ever happen in the future but there's no
solid information to suggest that this
rumor is true and though we got
discovered knows that the Intel about
Garfield being AI to play marbles
moonlights come from a source with a
quote pretty strong track record the
same source of leak the info about the
post-credits scene in the avengers
endgame rerelease plus the news about
the real Mandarin appearing in shang-chi
and the legend of the ten rings it's
just not possible to say with any
certainty how true this report really is
another thing complicating the idea that
Garfield will portray Moon Knight an
upcoming Marvel movie is the fact that
he isn't the only person said to be a
Marvel's wish list he's apparently only
one of several names Marvel is
reportedly considering for the role and
may have major competition in another
actor well-versed in the comic book
movie world
we got discovered citing the very same
source as evidently a bottomless well of
Marvel related information has also
claimed that the studio is eyeing Joseph
gordon-levitt the man behind police
officer John Blake in The Dark Knight
Rises like Garfield
Gordon Levitt is Jewish meaning there's
a chance our Marvel does have him on his
wish list if the outlets are the
reporters to be believed else we've said
this is all speculation for now only
time will tell if Marvel hands moonlight
the greatest gift of all a solo movie
and whether or not Garfield will be the
lucky guy to take the lead check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite superheros are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]